léon du groupe de résister sommes prêts
votre jeu wii prévoyait que le point
irait en ce qui concerne l'âge du cheval
à celui qui serait le plus près je vous
demande donc de bien vouloir vérifier
car cela change peut-être le score mais
ça change tout mais ça change tout
karimi immédiatement j'ai été saisi
d'une réclamation de ce qui m'entoure
c'est un point très précis du règlement
de ce jeu le point sera celui qui sera
le plus près de l'âge réel du cheval
voulez-vous vérifier et bien si vous
soulevez cette contestation pas une
contestation si vous soulevez sur une
constatation c'est bien ce que je
voulais dire si vous le voulez les
concurrents ont dit à chantilly neuf ans
c'est à dire que le concurrent de
chantilly se rapproche de l'âge du
cheval d'un an alors que le concurrent
de compiègne s'en rapproche de deux
années le point d'en gach chantilly fait
les comptes maintenant j'y vais je suis
désolé je suis désolé je ne suis pas
d'accord avec vous jeudi le poids le
point concernant l'âge du cheval ou le
point concernant la juge mal lotis
voulez-vous faire l'addition le point
concernant l'âge du cheval
on n'a jamais dit aux concurrents que
celui qui s'en rapprocherait le plus
gagnerait on agissait de donner le
chiffre exact je suis désolé léon
zitrone
léon zitrone 20 je vais tous les ans
oui il n'avait peut-être pas dit aux
concurrents mais moi j'avais pris le
soin de le dire à tous les organisateurs
pardon alors un salon avait alors dans
ces conditions vie je suis désolé encore
une fois mais c'est un désaccord celui
ci entre vous et moi
voudriez vous venir monsieur s'il vous
plaît voudriez vous venir monsieur
voudriez vous venir mon colonel
débouchés vos oreilles vous avez le
droit maintenant à la page 4 d'un
règlement que j'ai entre les mains à
léon zitrone
il est dit cinquième question allait
agir ensemble
voyez un cheval vous pouvez le tâter
vous avez trente secondes pour le faire
et pour dire son âge celui qui sera le
plus près de la vérité gagnera alors je
voudrais demander au public de compiègne
qui surtout la hausse sur les gradins
est un peu bruyant de bien vouloir nous
laisser en découdre mon ami dit et moi
je suis obligé de poser la question aux
concurrents est-ce que messieurs en
votre âme et conscience
ici nous pouvons avoir à faire car votre
mémoire est qu'à votre bonne foi qui est
entière comme celle de tout le monde
saviez vous que si vous ne donniez pas
linge exemple vous gagneriez si vous en
rapprocher le plus que votre adversaire
et ça ne change rien à la question les
onze il croise la route d'un stage pas
bon mais monsieur vitro nous étions pas
au courant des questions nous savions
absolument qu'une des questions
heureusement vous n'étiez pas encore des
questions séparées vous monsieur c'est
pas une affaire du bas qu'ici ce n'est
pas
mais je sais mon chèr léon vous êtes je
sais mon chariot que vous êtes très chou
mais enfin je suis désolé guy alors sur
ce point s'il vous plaît est en complet
désaccord avec vous je demande à pierre
brive de trancher la question et après
la biennale influencer le jury à rivière
je rappelle que pour une fois les on est
en plein désaccord avec moi et je suis
obligé d'être extrêmement strictes sur
le règlement avant avant que vous jugez
je vous rappelle les données il est dit
dans ce point concernant l'âge des
chevaux que le point qui ré justement
pour une de ces cinq questions
concernant l'âge des chevaux il est à
celui qui serait le plus près de l'âge
réel
alors maintenant je crois que pour
statuer ce n'est pas difficile avoue
paris oui enfin c'est pas dit c'est pas
difficile c'est vous qui le dites
mais la décision est déjà prise à
l'unanimité par les cinq membres du jury
et c'est monsieur garnier qui va nous la
donner si les concurrents ne connaissait
pas le résultat pas de résultats à
l'horizon
non non ce cas lisez pas les conditions
des conditions lors le résultat ému non
c'est pas ça
ayez attendait dit s'il vous plaît
veillez rue et rue et mais c'est comme
ça le jury à l'unanimité 10e s'y
attendait le jury a été semble-t-il très
influencé par ce qu'il dit léon zitrone
mais non pas parce qu'à dire écoutez moi
écouter dit il n'a pas été influencée
par ce qu'a dit léon zitrone
il a été influencé par ce qu'ont dit les
deux concurrents mais les deux
concurrents si ils n'ont pas estimé au
pot au courant du règlement c'est de la
faute à léon c'est pas de la faute au
règlement mais puisqu'ils ne savaient
pas puisqu'ils ne savait pas le jury
vous dites lui ses geôles est en fait un
règlement les on ne l'a pas lu ce n'est
pas pour ça qu'il ne pourra pas être
respecté mais si mais si mais si puisque
le jury vous dis d'ailleurs pierre brive
il est en train de lire le règlement les
ont regardés loges mais non mais non
mais c'est sûr
sinon je vois pas dans mes du nil et au
titre au jeu reprend une phrase qu'il
avait prononcée en 62 oh non tj oshie
voulez vous lire le point de règlement
que j'ai moi-même entre les mains que
vous avez aussi fait rien puisque les
concurrents ne l'ont pas mais les
concurrents ça n'a rien à voir mais si
mais si
alors là dit luxe et guy lux paris fera
le cas qu'il voudra le jury fera le cas
qu'il voudra de du renseignement que je
m'en vais lui donner mais pour ne pas
éternisé cette discussion
je vous affirme sur mon honneur
personnel que jamais je n'ai su que il y
aurait approximations dans cette
question jamais je ne lis eu et je ne
vois pas pourquoi il y aurait
approximations dans cette question
seulement on pouvait à ce moment là
aussi bien convenir qu'il y aurait
approximations dans la somme calculée
brévine opa répondait ni l'un ni l'autre
merveille ont maintenant attention il y
a maintenant un avis et celui des des
représentants de compiègne et de
chantilly d'abord les hommes avant toute
chose si gentille marqué ce point avancé
en dans les chevaux est ce que ça
changerait le score devait bien entendu
guy bien entendu dans un match nul il y
aurait match nul alors c'est très lourd
de conséquences car est également lourd
de conséquences car tout à l'heure
n'ayant pas respecté un pointe du
règlement qui est écrit noir sur blanc
et bien vous allez peut-être privé une
ville d'une victoire ce n'est pas du
tout cela dit j'en suis absolument
désolé nous pouvons ne pas être d'accord
vous et moi nos désaccords ma foi nous
les arrangeront il y à une question très
simple on a joué à compiègne ce une
manière pour les cette manière là qui
doit peut-être oui
léon zitrone qu'ils avaient même si le
règlement il n'aurait pas connu l'âge du
cheval pour autant mais ça n'empêche pas
c'est comme ça il peut pas il est en
fait je ne suis pas d'accord
ils n'ont pas trouvé l'âge du cheval ce
n'est pas pour cela qu'il devait ignorer
règlement ça me paraît quand même grave
de l'autre le jeune maire d'une autre je
vous demande pardon qui le chou je vous
demande pardon tu sais ce que je puisse
avoir en tête
oui moi je vous donne volontiers alors
merci dit je m'excuse de vous
l'apprendre un peu brutalement monsieur
tard si vous représentez chantilly je
vous demande de nous éclairer oui pour
nous pour les organisateurs du jeu pour
les téléspectateurs qui nous font
l'amitié d'être avec nous est ce que
vous estimez que vous êtes battus
vraiment normalement sincèrement ou bien
à votre avis vous êtes plaisait non je
ne m'estime pas lésés mais j'étais
persuadé d'avoir le
le rayon gagnant quand j'ai vu disant
que moi j'avais marqué neuf ans est ce
que vous vous exprimez les et je
m'estime fallait oser mais j'étais
persuadé d'avoir si c'est vrai ce que tu
dis mais je m'estime noisy symphonic son
concurrent est d'accord avec le
règlement il n'était plus prêt que
l'autre alors dans ces conditions je
vous ai dit tout ce que j'avais à vous
dire guy je renvoie une fois de plus la
peine à paris
je vous ai donné mon opinion trois fois
moins rose moi aussi je voulais donner
quatre mois et bien alors que paris sera
oui ben écoute et avant tout le juré a
la gentillesse de prendre bien tout ça
et assister à votre longue discussion
je me fais l'interprète non pas de la
majorité mais d'unanimité c'est bien
d'accord de l'unanimité pour dire que
puisque les deux concurrents ont avoué
très loyalement qui ne savaient ni l'un
ni l'autre cette petite clause
le résultat est acquis c'est à dire
qu'il ya une victoire et non pas un
match nul voilà la décision du jury de
paris tout gentiment les décisions des
jurys vol pour une fois j'ai
l'impression que cette décision n'est
pas très juste mais cela dit ce lundi
jean nous saurons pas plus chergui chéri
le jury ne vous tient pas rigueur de
cette remarque sur lui j'ai l'impression
que le jury ne connaissait pas de
règlement non plus mais cela dit nous
serons pas plus royalistes que le roi
puisque monsieur le maire de chantilly
quels premiers lésés me dit après tout
repos on va nous le faisions un décision
du jury moi à regarder si les gentils le
maire de chantilly
1 alors bravo pour tout le monde et
maintenant épreuves suivantes avoue
simone